everyone in fact will be either
religious or superstitious I'm not
superstitious but I am a little stitious
I looked up the Webster definition of
superstition because I wanted to be
totally precise here the dictionary
definition of superstition is a belief
or practice resulting from ignorance
fear of the unknown trust in magic or
chance or a false conception of
causation you will either be a religious
person religion is of course the uh
Habit of virtue that inclines the will
to give to God what he deserves you will
you will either be religious and
acknowledge God and then follow that
logic with your heart and with your
whole spirit and with your logic
theology is faith- seeking understanding
and you will apply the rigors of of
logic to your intuitions of the
metaphysical or you'll just believe in
magic and and chance and Superstition
and all of this cookiness